[музика]
пил дим село і техно
А я от сам кладу от найгарнішу купу з
усікла побачите от Приходьте через
хвилин 30 тут буде найкраще
це рейв толока яка що вихідних приваблює
десятки людей
тут атмосфера яка стати ще треба і тут
дуже класна
[музика]
В цьому році я з'їздив перше на
пасхальну толку і з тих пір відмінив усі
плани на вихідні для того щоб їхати сюди
Валерій учитель математики це вже його
сьома толока
якийсь момент через роботу знайомитися з
новими людьми стало важкувато коли ти
знайомишся з людьми під час ланцюжку
цегли під час спільної роботи у вас
якась спільна справа комунікація
набагато легше і тому нових знайомих
знаєте набагато легких Це село ягідне на
Чернігівщині торік воно пережило
окупацію і постраждало від бойових дій
завдання для толокерів на сьогодні
розібрати завали зруйнованого спортзалу
формуємо ланцюжки бігти до цього стояли
в ланцюжках прошу переходити на
підбирання цегли
На жаль спортивний зал не підлягає
відновленню і його збиралися
бульдозерами взагалі знести і вивести
все на
захисник всі матеріали Але
зрозуміло що там є багато дуже цегли
здається всі цеглини на експертизу і
виявили що ці цеглини можна
переписувати на будівництві в подальшому
молоді добровільно платить невеликий
внесок аби приїхати сюди попрацювати під
музику для багатьох це відпочинок який
можна собі дозволити під час війни я
Запоріжжя Мені дуже багато друзів з
Херсона Це був дуже важкий тиждень і я
дуже радію що зараз у мене є нагода Хоча
б трошки відволіктися від усіх цих новин
і цього того що дуже відчувається ми не
проти на фронті в мене це
багато друзів знайомих на фронті
відповідно це великий стрес учасників
привозять автобусами з Києва годують
хоча це здебільшого типова міська молодь
тут почуваються як вдома
ну я сам з Чернігова якби Чернігівська
область рідне і
робиш щось корисне Я думаю це в першу
чергу мотивує один раз коли ми
приїжджали я не пам'ятаю як це було село
Чи буде чи Слобода то нас місцеві
зустрічались зі сльозами мали і як би це
ми один народ одна родина одна сім'я і
потрібно допомагати толуки на
Чернігівщині почалися майже одразу після
деокупації за цей час місцеві вже звикли
сільські рейви нікого не дивують коли ми
вперше приїхали казали боже хто вони
понаїхали якісь зеки вони всі в наколках
якісь непонятних прическах а непонятних
нарядок а потім десь толок 5 і нам вже
ой діти приїхали Давай до вас нагодуємо
давайте вареники давайте ще щось дітки
молодці
молодий як мурашечки я тоже чоловіку
Кажу скільки вже нас кидали Он дивіться
молодці
ягідне це те саме село де росіяни майже
місяць тримали у шкільному підвалі 370
місцевих жителів
12 з них загинули
пані Тамара разом зі своїм песиком
вижили мені хорошо Я люблю музику нічого
Хорошо я вже привикла і в тому році дуже
багато допомагали і у мене ж будинок як
згорів Так зараз ще ж таки оце як оці з
будинки сильно багато Отож згореного
кирпичів і ото блока допомагали
приїжджали так автобусами приїжджали і
допомагали Оце ж клуб вибирали Здрасті і
ти участвуешь Ромка
да А собі
доля цегли зі спортзалу теж хвилює
місцевих волонтери планують з неї
будувати нові будинки в іншому селі
Лукашівці кажуть що відновлювати ягідне
почали вже чимало іноземних організацій
а в Лукашівці такого немає Утім не всі
жителі ягідного з цим згодні
неприємно що що вивозять хай би у нас
сараї немає і в мене будинок то
пообіцяли Латвія збудувати
А старайтесь ніхто не обіцяє мені ж ніде
не курочки більше часу ніде нічого а
вона одна з кирпич вивозять Ну так дали
мені щоб добудувати той решту
чого ж мені не дати
тим часом у Лукашівці теж триває робота
це один з п'яти будинків які за рік
збудували в селі волонтери уже є стіни
вікна дах але внутрішніх робіт ще чимало
оця булька має бути Тіпа по центру е-е
плюс-мінус і ти тоді
повиставляєш сначала сам цей рівень
Сергій єдиний професійний будівельник у
цій команді але працює як волонтер він
керує процесом і навчає інших наприклад
на наступних вихідних мене не буде я їм
дам фронт робіт покажу що до чого як
робити вони самі без мене нормально
справляться тому з них можна вже сказати
вже дає деякий досвід навіть думаю що
всього цю проводку наприклад вони
тягнули самі я в цьому навіть не я
тільки розмальовував Куди що де має іти
це вони все самі роблять тому розумні
якщо розумні працювати то не все вийде Я
думаю пані Тамара власниця цього будинку
поки що вона живе у сусідів про колишню
домівку залишилися лише спогади війна
зруйнувала її ущент взагалі
що горить запалило воно її от хати
загорівся гараж загорівся хлів А мене
були свині все повбивало і діти в мене
оничок у 8 днів приїхали
у погреб у погребів 8 днів сиділо дитя в
Погреби місяць
Так переживали їх Як вона буде після
звільнення села за нього взялися
волонтери тепер для пані Тамари вони
майже як рідні хоча спершу жінка не
вірила що як вона каже діти і завали
розчистять і будинок з нуля зведуть
хату
Ну що ви хочете щоб у вас вдома ну
конечно хочемо можете зробити
а не сміятися ну попробуємо Я думаю нуш
Ну діти ну що вони вони зовсім не по
спеціальності
прийде не так
перероблюють так дівчата клали клали
дівчата ну подивлюсь так Ну як ти
мурашечки Після робочого дня вночівляв
наметах озеро багаття зграї комарів
нарив чи дискотеку нема сил але за
тиждень більшість із цих хлопців і
дівчат повернуться Знову вони вірять що
відбудувати Україну можна Саме так